there's little doubt the corona virus
pandemic began in China also that it
wasn't man-made but there's huge
uncertainty as to how it jumped from
animal to human well thank you very much
please Donald Trump appears to support a
theory it came from a laboratory in the
city of Wuhan he even claims to have
seen evidence US intelligence partner
Australia isn't so sure it sees a wet
market as the most likely culprit this
is one of the four reasons why it is
important that we just have a an
objective independent assessment of how
this originated and learn the lessons
from how that occurred Britain too is
looking for answers and wants to work
with allies including China but it's
unclear if Beijing feels the same the
World Health Organisation told Sky News
yesterday it hasn't been invited to join
a Chinese investigation into coronavirus
and the wh OHS representative in China
also says he's not yet seen logs from a
key laboratory we have visited the
provincial CDC lab it's not it's not the
biosafety level 4 lab that people have
been talking about but the visit was not
it was part of our Wuhan visit but it
was more a look at the facilities as
opposed to an investigation of the logs
for example this is the Wuhan Institute
of virology US and European intelligence
agencies are looking at whether the
pandemic may have been triggered by an
accidental leak the Institute's been
carrying out research on coronaviruses
in that it has the highest level of
international bio research safety level
4 but US officials reportedly issued
warnings about inadequate safety after
visiting in 2018 how likely is it that
this virus escaped by accident from a
laboratory in Wuhan viruses and other
microbiological items have gone missing
from
for laboratories you know in the US and
other first world countries so it's not
beyond the bounds of possibility
China reject claims any laboratory was
at fault
it also says it's been open and
transparent but Washington's threatening
new tariffs as anger mounts Deborah
Haynes Sky News